楽しさの障害物という
まあ言葉を変えて言えばね
なんで楽しめないのかと
頑張っても頑張ってもなんか楽しめないんですね
これはどういうことかとわからない
そういうふうなことで
何か我々の心にちょっとした問題があるんです
その楽しさを妨げてるものってどういうものかと
仏典から説明したいと思います
で 最初の一応書いてる通りのものですけど
まずはこちらで書いてはないんですけど
この過去ということを問題にするんです
今日は 楽しくないのは
この過去がなんか引っかかっているんです
例えば例えば子供たちは随分無邪気で楽しいでしょうにね
いないいないばあと言ったってば
えらい喜んじゃうでしょうね
なんで大人になったらもうとんでもない
ど派手なことしたって
別に面白くも楽しくもなくなっちゃうんですね
大人と子供の違いっていうのは
子供には過去がないし
だから純粋なんですね
我々の過去があるんですよ
だからそこら辺に問題があります
まあ今日は話は全部できるだけバイリンガルでいこうかなと
我々の過去の経験というのは Is a ghost that haunts your home of happiness
で まあ何でしたっけ 過去っていうのは幸福の家っていう
まあ我々は楽しくいたいんですけどね
その幸福の家を家に憑かれている物の怪ですね
それはもう一応結論で
過去っていうのは物の怪だよと
ということから 全部結論からもう話を進めていきたいと思います
ですから 最初からもう我々の過去っていうのは
まあただの物の怪 これが怖いくて
我々の幸福の家をね 取り憑かれていろいろ邪魔をしているんですね
お化けが憑いてると なんか家でね
安心して寝られないでしょうね One
should not mistake it as a guardian spirit. ほとんどの人々は自分の過去
自分の経験 あれやこれやとか大事なものだと自分を守ってくれるんだと思ってます
過去がなかったらまあどうしようもないでしょうと
だから我々はこの守護霊だと思ってるんですよ
過去は ですからもう最初から言います
この過去っていうのは
別に自分を何らかで守ってくれる守護霊じゃないんです
もうただの物の怪だと思った方がいいんじゃないかなと
はい それでまあ それから仏教の普通の調子に戻ります
仏教っていうのも 何でも定義して言葉をしっかりするんです
曖昧にさせないようにと
そういうことで 過去って何ですか？という定義なんですね What
does past mean? 過去って過去っていうのはどういうものなのかと
過去といえば 3つ これはできるだけ厳密に経典に沿っちゃうと
もうやりきれないんですね
量が多すぎて だからできるだけぎゅっと単純化しちゃったんです
1番目は経験 experience ということ
2番目は知識 knowledge
3番目はもう感情 この順番をつけたのは一般の皆様の立場からなんです
皆様に過去って何なのかと聞いたっても
その 3つだよとは言えないと思いますけど
一応みんな過去と言えば経験ということは大変大事に思っちゃうし
勉強した知識はすぐに大事に思っちゃうし
感情っていうものはそんなにほとんど無視するんですよ
ですから この俗世間から見ると順番です
仏教から言うともうちょっと変わりますけどね
順番は それで覚えてください
過去という定義は経験
知識 感情という 3つ それで These three factors are motive forces of living.
我々はこの 3つので生きてるんですよ
それが衝動になって 生きる機動力になって
日々生きてるんですよ
日々生きてるためには
もうエネルギーになっているのは
バイキになっているのはこの過去なんです
過去と言ったっても この 3つなんです
3番目の感情が過去っていうのは
なかなかスッと入ら入ってこないんですか
そのうち入るでしょう
まあ説明続きますからね
まずこの定義だけ覚えておいてください
それで理解指導費の一番最後に書いてる行なんです
我々の生きるエネルギーって何なのかというと
この三つの過去なんですよ
それで生きているんです
知識も経験もいろいろ感情もエネルギーになって生きているんです
はい それで過去のカテゴライズ
いろいろ types of past 過去というのはいろんなタイプに分けられます
これでもう仏教の順番に書いたんです
だから三は一番上に来るんですね
emotions ということをちょっと大きく書いたんですけど
それから経験なんですね
知識っていうのは番目なんですよ
これ 仏教から見るとそういうことなの
人間というのはそっちを知識で生きてるわけじゃないんですよ
たまたまですよ その知識使うのは
結局は emotion 感情で生きているんです
それからいろいろ経験
だからこれは正しい順番なんですね
それでその emotion というものでも
感情もつに分けられます
で 一番目は普通の感情
番目は profitable と書いてあって
向こうで日本語にしているのはあれなんですね
メリットなんとかという言葉使いますけどね
まあ友好的な役に立つ感情
それから unprofitable 役に立たない感情がありまして
それが destructive 自分を破壊へ導く
あるいは陥れる感情があるんです
だから感情にしたっても
そういったメスはありまして
それから experience の場合も経験の場合も
普通な経験があって 友好的な役に立つ経験があって
全然役に立たない経験もありまして
それから自分を陥れる
破壊する経験もあります
で 知識の場合も同じつありますまあ
ごく普通な知識と役に立つ有効な知識と
それから役に立たない知識と
番目 破壊的な自分の幸福をなくして陥れる知識というの知識も種類あります
まあそんなに難しいことではないと思いますけど
まあ後で説明入るとは思います
だから私は言いたいのは一概にね
感情何やと一遍に簡単に決めるんじゃなくて
感情も種類あります まあごく普通にあるものとか
まあ分かりやすく言えば
例えばちょっとお腹が空いた
何か美味しいものでも食べようとかね
それも気持ち気分ですけどね
別にそれってね ごく普通でしょうね
この花が綺麗やとかね
だからそれは general 普通のカテゴリに入るんですね
極普通 別にいいとも悪いともなんでもないんです
で 有効的な感情っていうのは
自分をより活発に明るく
あの 生かされる 押してくれる感情なんですね
人を助けなくちゃあかんとかね
もう何とかいいことをしなくちゃいけないんだぞとかね
そうやって湧いてくる感情っていうのはprofitableであって
あるいは逆にunprofitable役に立たないっていうのは
もう嫌になっちゃって
もう何でもやりたくないぞとか言って寝込んだりするとかね
それも感情なんで それは良くない感情でね
破壊的感情っていうのは
いきなりそれも同じく嫌になっちゃって
あの女の子が人を殺しちゃったで
ちょっとした感情でしょうに
誰でもちょっと嫌み言われると気分が悪いんですけど
あの子にとってはそれは破壊的なところまで行ってしまったんですね
ですから 感情もそういう風にありまして
経験もそういう風に四つありまして
知識もありますよ 知識は何でもいいわけじゃないんですよ
まずどうしても知っておかなくちゃいかないという常識という知識がありますね
誰でも それはいいとも悪いでもなくて
誰も知っておかなくちゃいけない
それから有効的な役に立つ仕事になる知識がありますね
それからただ知識はあるんですけど
何の役にも立ちませんという知識もあります
ギリシャ語は勉強したんですけど
別に仕事にも使えないし
話す相手もないしという
別にギリシャ語で書かれた本もないんだよと
言うと まあ知識なんですけど
別に役には立ってはないんですね
そういう知識もあります
それからdestructというものすごい破壊的な知識もありますね
例えば 麻原さんのグループに入った若者っていうのは結構知識人でしょうね
そこはいかに社会を破壊するのかっていうことに使ってしまったんですね
だからこの知識も破壊的にもなります
そういうことで だいたいそういう風ないろいろ種類ありますよっていうことを覚えておいてください
一応三つ 四つで分けてみると
十二種類でしたっけ？ぐらいはあります
そこから問題なんです
で 十二種類の過去がありますよ
過去と言ったっても十二種類なんです
この十二種類の過去のいろんな部品が合わせてフィルターを作るんですよ
現在に いつでも十二種類をまとめてフィルターを作ってるわけじゃないんです
あれこれやと十二種類もありますからね
いろんな組み合わせできるんですよ
一個だけフィルターに入るとかね
一つの色で 二個だけフィルターに入って色を二つにするとか
そういう風にこのフィルターがフィルターオブパストという個人個人に生きる時はかなり壁が鉄の壁というかフィルターがあります This
filter blockades your present experience.と英語で書いてますけど
このフィルターは現在の事実に直接することが妨げる
だから生きているのは現在でしょうに
でも直接する 直接接することできないんですよ
フィルター通さないと
これが問題なんです 美味しいなのにフィルター通しちゃいますから
美味しくなくなっちゃうんですよ
例えば美味しい食べ物なのに
何の味気もない何か衣で巻いて食べさせると美味しくはないでしょうに
薬の場合はよくあれは美味しくないんだからね
砂糖のなんとか 何でしたっけ？あれはコーティングして本当に美味しくないのに
それで美味しいと騙されるでしょうね
そういう風に我々の現在経験全てコーティングしていますけど
経験がコーティングしているわけじゃないんです
自分が受ける側がその都度その都度いろいろコーティングしているんです
これはもうどうしても避けられないことになってますから
一般の人々には人生楽しもうと思っても
これが障害物なんですよ
このフィルターが ですから我々は見ていると言ったっても
本当は見てない 聞いてると言ったっても
本当は聞いてない 味わってると言っても本当は味わってない
例えばいろいろ勉強とか考えてやってます
で言ったっても 本当はやってないんですよ
フィルターがかかってるんです
だから中途半端なんですよ
例えば何か一時間ぐらい勉強したっても
せいぜい二割しか頭に入らないんですよ
それも時間経つと六割消えてしまうんですよ
頭に入ったものの中でも
なぜかというと このフィルターとおっしゃいますから
フィルターでもうかなり止まってもらうんですね
例えば音楽を聴いたりしていても
純粋に聞いて楽しんでるわけじゃないんです
かなり落としてます フィルターで
そういうことだから 生きていたっても生きてないことになってるんですよ
このフィルターがすごい厚いんだったら
もう私は平気で言うんですよ
生きてないんだよと 大体この自然の中で派手な文明とか何ともない世界でフィルターがすごく薄いんです
バカでかい建物もないし
そんなド派手な文化もないし
もう最低時計さえないとかね
ただ何か作って 何かもう栽培して
それで取って食べて 疲れたら寝て
また明るくなったら起きてとかね
そういう 例えばまあ不足的な生活とかね
やってると このフィルター
我々文化人側にある分厚いフィルターがないんです
しかし 人間なら面白いことは
そういう人々もあえてフィルター作るんですよ
例えば山に入る前にちゃんと神様にお祈りしなくちゃいけないとかね
この日はもう狩りに行ってはいけないとかね
あらゆる仕来り習慣 それでもあります
この木を取ってはいけないとか
人が死んじゃったら その奥さんがもう三ヶ月間も住んでるあの小さなあれ
ハットから出て出てはいけないとかね
あるいは体中灰を塗って
もう一ヶ月間も あの 何て言いますか
人が死んじゃったら  喪に服する
喪に服す 喪に服されなくちゃいけないとかね
そういういろいろフィルターが一応作るんです
とにかくこのフィルターがあるんだっていうことを覚えておけばいいんじゃないかなと思います
はい そういうことで触れられない現実があるんですよ Present
is unnoticed
現実っていうのはもう気づかないものであると
で あの言葉で説明したことではなくて
別なポイントこちらで書いてます Though
we feel happy, we are not sure of it.たとえ楽しみであっても
あまり鈍感というかね
本当に楽しいなと聞いたらちょっと戸惑っちゃうんですよ
試しに聞いてみてください
誰かがすごい楽しんでる時
突然「あのね あんた本当に楽しいんですか？」とすごい真剣な顔で聞いてみてください
答えられなくなっちゃう
戸惑っちゃって ほんと楽しんでるのかと
それがフィルターのおかげなんですよ
子供に聞いたら楽しいですか？といきなり楽しいと言うでしょ
逆にお大人に聞いてみてください
本当に楽しいっていう風に聞かないとね
言うと初めて気づくんですよ
やっぱり自分が楽しいと言ってるんですけど
結局本当に楽しいのかと
これが 鈍感なんで We
do not know what it is and why
英語と日本訳は少々ニュアンスが違うと思いますけど
楽しみについて何を楽しいか
なぜ楽しいかは知らない
酒飲んで楽しいって言うんですけど
何を楽しいか なぜ楽しいかというね
全然知らないんですよ
楽しみの出現も消滅も知らないっていうことは We
do not know how does it rise and ceases to be.私たちはどのように楽しみが現れてきて
なんで何か現象が現れたら楽しいということになったんでしょうかと
なんでそれは消えていくんでしょうかと
なんで楽しくなくなったんでしょうかとかね
そういうスタディはしないんですよ
例えば酒でもよろしいし
美味しいご飯でもよろしいし
一口食べると一口飲むと楽しいとかね
で  2回目はどうなってるんで
3回目はどうなってるんでしょうかと
そこでこの楽しみがこうやって本当は変わって減っていくはずなんですけど
全然気づかないんですよ
食べ過ぎになったりもするのはそういうわけなんです
美味しいと思ってるだけで
突然攻撃的に質問すると
あんたこれ本当に美味しいでしょうか？って言ってわからないんですよ
美味しいだと思って食べて食べて食べて
また食べ過ぎになってしまうんです
だから人間楽しいと言ってもえらいもう変ですよ
特にこの英語で書いたこのHow does it rise and ceases to beというのはなくなることですね
これもうわからない それを本当に知っておかないと
これは純粋な仏教の世界なんですね
仏教はそういうふうに物事を見てくださいと言ってるんですね
次の日本語で読みます
楽しみの次 必ず我々の悲しみ
落ち込みに気づかない
大体順番ですごく楽しんだら次に落ち込んじゃうんです
それも知らないんです
そうすると頭混乱してまた変なことをやったりするんです
今 楽しみについて説明しましたけど
苦しみについてあっても同じなんですよ
もういきなり落ち込んでいるのであって
なんで苦しいなのか どのようにこれ現れてきたのかとかね
どのようにそれ消えていくのかという
そんなのは気にしないで
ただ悲しがっちゃうんです
本当に悲しんでる人にも聞いてみてください
すごいしつこく ちょっと聞けないかもしれませんだけど
あんた本当に悲しいんですかと
本当に悲しいんでしょうかと
好きな人が亡くなったとか
何とかに別れてとかね
しつこく聞くと本人が結構戸惑うと思います
それで悲しみが消えちゃうと次に落ち着きがあるんですよ
それにも気づかないんです
楽しみが消えると次に落ち込みがあります
苦しみが消えていくと
楽しみが消えていくと次に落ち着きがあります
どちらを選ぶのかと でもそういうセットでしか出てこないよ
だから楽しみたい楽しみたいというと
五分五分よりも以上落ち込まなくちゃいけなくなるんです
苦しいや人生悲しいやと言ったっても
それ消えない 消えてしまうと結構落ち着きが現れます
テレビでいろいろ子供が殺されたとか何とかとかということで
親とか出るでしょうに
激しい怒りと憎しみと混乱で
もう悩んでいて ある時期が消えたらものすごく穏やかになっちゃって
普通の日本語日本人よりはかなりもう人格的で
もう 加害者側に対しても
そういうもう心配するぐらいにも成長する落ち着きがある人々もいるんでしょう
日本でも だからあれはあまりにも悲しいんだから
次に必然的に出てくる結果なんです
そこら辺で混乱しちゃうと
それも出てこないんですよ
だからどんな経験にしても
悲しいであろうか 楽しいであろうか
苦しいであろうか 何であろうか
現れて消えていくし そのプロセスがあるし
なぜ現れるのかもあるし
消えたらどうなるのかっていうものを大体法則的にパターンになってます
そこで忘れられた現実Forgotten present
大体みんなForgotten pastと言いたいでしょ
英語の言葉でもそうなってますよ
忘れられ忘れた過去とかね
私は仏教で忘れた現在
我々は現在 今現実を忘れているんです
だからYou have not lost your past but the present.過去はなくなっているわけじゃないんです
現在忘れている なくなっているんですよ Your
progress is stuck at the rock call past.人間の生き方
進み方はこのあるロックの崖があって
そこにぶつけているんです
その崖が過去なんです
だから知られない現実ということを言った方が正しいんですね
過去は常に崖のごとく人の道を妨害して立っている
我々にはこの過去がもう崖のように前にも立って遮っているんですよ
現実は見えないようにしているんです
それで答えなんですけど
過去は現実ではなく もののけだと知る人は
霧を遮って進むように前へ進むんですよ
過去っていうのはもうあり得もしないし
現実でもないし ただのもののけだと
見たら これは崖ではなくて
ちょっと霧みたいなことになります
霧ぐらいだったら通していけるでしょうね
ちょっと不安かもしれませんだけど
そんなに先が見えませんだから
それでも通れないわけじゃないんです
しかし 人間にとっては
過去は大変な重い荷物で
もうかなり高い崖になってますよ
ということで まあ分かりやすいですね
言っていることは だから
なんで人が向上しないのか
なんで人が進歩しないのかとかね
なんで人生はうまくいかないのかと
なんで幸福にならないのかと聞けば
ただもう崖にぶつけているんです
過去という崖に それが私たちはそれが実際するんだと
現実は実際しないというか
見てないんですよ それで崖にぶつけてもう進めなくなるんです
それでそんなに気にする必要ない過去っていうのは
もうものの でしたらどうでもいいんですよ
別にそんなのはもうただの頭の中だけの話でしょ
実際にいるわけじゃないでしょうに
いると思っちゃうと怖くて怖くてたまらんでしょうね
お化けでも幽霊でも憑いていると思っちゃうと
もうもう怖くてたまらないんですよ
それで何があってもそれを幽霊のせいにする
で キリがなくなっちゃうんですね
それで祈祷師が来てお金を持って帰るんですね
それでも心の問題が治らない限りは
はい まあ一応ここら辺分かりやすいと思います
それで このフィルターの働き How
does the filter of past work?どのように働くかと It
destroys the appreciation of the present moment as it is by obstructing the
experience with a series of past experiences, thoughts, and emotion
s.こう書けばすごく難しくなりますけどね
英語で考える人にとってはそんなに難しい文章ではないんですけど
フィルターが現在の経験をありのままに見て評価することを
過去の経験 思考 感情を流し込んで妨げるんですよ
だから現実をそのまま見ようではないか
美味しいものはそのまま美味しいと味わおうではないかと
楽しいことは素直に楽しもうではないかと思いたいが
ずーっと流れ込むんですよ
このフィルターに情報が
過去の経験と感情 それからあらゆる思考が流れ込んで厚いフィルターが作っちゃうんです
そうすると素直に楽しめなくなっちゃうんです
このお花は綺麗やっていうことが言えなくなっちゃうんです
このご飯美味しいとかね
言えなくなるんですよ
そういうわけでWhat you see, you see what your past commands you to see
.我々が見たり聞いたり味わったりしているのは現実じゃないんですよ
あの過去が命令するんです
過去が命令するものを見ているのであって
本物を見てないんです
劇場に行ったら 誰かが強引に首をあっち見なさいと後ろの方に回されているような感じで
舞台が見えなくなっちゃうんです
で 本人は劇場に行ったとかね
自分も演奏 その舞台演奏に参加しましたと思ってはいるんですけど
実際は見てないんですね
なんとなくこの後見ていたっても音とか聞こえるかもしれませんし
照明があっちこっち変わったり変わるとそれは聞こえてるかもしれませんし
だから半端ですね 劇場に行ったならば
じーっと舞台を見ていた方がいいでしょう
何も考えないで その方が結構美しく見えて感動はできる
誰か強引に首を他の方に回しておいちゃうと
もうどうにもならんですね
そこで 日々我々の人生はいつでも過去がヤクザみたいに命令しているんです
だから見ても見させてくれない
聞いても聞かせてくれない
味わおうとしても味わわせてくれない
考えようとしても考えさせてくれない
決まってるパターンでやらなくちゃいけない
なんだかんだで あなたは自分の過去が命令しているものを押し付けているものですね
見たり聞いたりしているのです
それで現実は知らないという論理になります
はい 次に行きます また鈴木ですけどHow does the field of past work?ということで
例えなんですね For
example, a man oppressed with sad reminiscence of past cannot enjoy a dance
party.すごい単純な例なんですよ
例えば人がね すごい悲しい何か思い出が出てきて
かなり抑えられてるんですよ
悲しみの思い出に そこなのに
自分の部屋の隣にダンスパーティーやってるかもしれません
その人に参加できないんですよ
もうすごい悲しい状況に陥っているんだから
だから たとえ誰かが死んだと情報が入ってきてあっても
現実は自分の隣の部屋でみんな友達がパーティーやってるということなんです
友達がパーティーやってるんだったら
それに参加して楽しみっていうことは
今の時計で言えば今の現実なんです
でも入った情報っていうのは過去の情報なんです
それがあの楽しみをもうカットするんです
そういう風にこのフィルターが頑張っちゃうんです
これ詳しくいろいろ 例えば皆様絵画見ようかな
展覧会に行こうかなと言ったっても
あの行く前に厚いカタログを勉強したり
いろいろ情報を調べたりしてフィルター作るんですよ
時々みんなこの競りですっごい高い値段つけたらつけられたら
ただそれだけの理由であの絵を
絵画を見て なんて美しいでしょうか
とんでもない嘘なんですけど
値段つけたんだからといって
芸術的にすごい最高っていうことはないんですけど
私はもう何も知らない子供たちが描く絵とかはね
ものすごいインパクト強く感じる時もありますよ
でもまあ子供の絵だからといって捨てますけどね
まあ子供には表現力がそんなにたくさんないのは当たり前なんですけど
テクニックもないのは当たり前なんですけど
でも子供が持っているテクニックで自分言いたいこと
表したいことは見事に表してくれたりする場合あります
それはすごい評価するべきですけど
でもそれはまあ 母親か父親ぐらいはそれを置いておいて抱く
置いておくだけ 誰も評価しない
だからこの加工のフィルターが入り込んじゃって
イギリスのあのあれ なんとかで
で まああの すごいもう何億も値段値札がついたと
それはもう初めて外国でもう日本で見られるんだろうと言ったら
みんな走って見るんですね
で 素直に評価できないんですよ
それで私みたいなアホな人がね
こんなのははっきり素直に見て
嫌だったら嫌と言ってくださいって言っても言わないんですよ
そこで感情が割り込むんです
そんなこと言ったら私の立場がとかね
ということで ということで
曲げても見えなくなっちゃうんです
美味しくない食べ物でも
まあフランス料理だったら美味しいでしょ
結構臭いものも食べますけど
フランス人は  舌に入れた途端
もう吐きたくなるようなものも食べてますけど
でもこれはもうフランス料理で言っちゃえば
みんなもうなんて美味しいですかと
カビと虫が入ってるチーズも食べてるでしょうに
でも美味しいでしょ？フランス料理だから
だからそういう風に我々はフィルター掛けるんですよ
どこかの部族で 村で もう森の中で
土の中に穴を掘って そこで火を焚いて
そこで石を流し込んで
そこで何か芋とか何とか入れて
葉っぱで何とかして料理しちゃうと美味しくないんですね
実際はそれを見たんだからね
まあこう NHKと一緒にちょっとなんとか仕事終わって行ってね
これはまあまずいなとか言いながらね
みんな食べてたんですけど
そしたら逆にヨーロッパ人が作ってるの
あんなの食べ物かと 人間には食い物じゃないって
だって油やらバターやらもう大量に入れて
それでキャベツぐらい炒めるだけのことで
原始的な人はそうじゃなくて
すごい自然の材料をもう石をギューッと温めて入れて
その上に葉っぱを持ってきて
これで煮物入れて また葉っぱ入れて
また石を入れて その上に土をかけたんです
いっぱい こうやってじっと待っていて
それから土を外出して食べ物を
私はあれはもう自然のね
土の香りやら葉っぱの香りやら入って
で 水 1滴もなく ただ自然の熱でね
殺菌 洗剤 それから味付けっていうのは 0
何もしてないでしょ あれこそ人間の食べ物だと思ったんですけど
まあ言えなくて フィルターかかっちゃって
で いろいろ私にアドバイス聞くんだからね
昨日聞いたことは言わなくちゃいけないということで
時々は言いましたけど
理解してくれなかったんです
そういうふうなことで
我々にはフィルターが働くんですよ
働かない人は言わせませんよ
ちょっと大げさに言うんです
そうするともう分かりますよ
だから美味しくないものでも
フランス料理なら美味しいやと風に覚えておけば
この理屈を論理が覚えやすいんです
別に皆さんを侮辱しているわけじゃなくて
この頭にしっかり何とかして覚えさせたいんです
そういうポイント はい
それで various aspects of past
様々な過去 様々な過去
それで過去といえば この経験と知識と感情ですね
過去っていうのは それを一つ一つ説明していきたいと思います
1番目 experience 経験っていうのは面白いことで one get tired of tha
t one had already experience
ということで 経験というのはよく慣れていることに
経験していることに飽きるんですね
未練を感じないんですね
結婚 20年目ぐらいでみたいな感じで
もう楽しくなくなっちゃうんです
経験の問題はそういうことなんです
例えば家でお風呂に入ってる
ずっと家にお風呂に入ってる方々は
もう旅館とか あるいは銭湯とか行った途端
あの大きさに驚く 驚くでしょ
もう楽しくなっちゃうんです
なんて大きいですかと
大人だから走り回らないんですけど
走り回りたい気分にはなります
子供は走り回ってこけたり
いろいろ大変ですけど
それで 2日目  3日目行ってみてください
全然面白くなくなっちゃうんです
この旅館でもいいんだから 1
週間ぐらい泊まってみてください
早く帰りたくなるんですよ
毎日すごいご馳走が出ているのに
毎晩 でも毎晩同じものだからね
旅館どこでもね だから一回だけ行って一晩だけ泊まると
なんで贅沢でしょうかと思うんだけど
2日目  3日目はね すごく飽きちゃうんです
これが経験の問題ですよ
だから飽きることによって現在を楽しめなくなるんですよ
だから過去の経験が邪魔するんです
3日目の旅館は楽しめなくなっちゃうんです
何か別なこと何かしない限りは
そこで 2日間の経験がもうフィルター作っちゃったんです
ここで知識の場合も同じことなんですね
One loses one's interest in the matters one already knows. よく知っていることに
すでに知っていることには興味がない
子供の頃読んだ絵本なんか
今読んでも面白くないでしょう
でも子供の頃 えらい感動したでしょうに
どうなってるんですかね
なんで今絵本読んで楽しめないんですかね
本屋さんに行ったっても
そこら辺は見落としないでしょう
自分に子供がいないならば
自分に子供がいるんだったら
あの児童文学の方に行きますけど
スーパー デパートに行ったっても
おもちゃ売り場に行かないでしょ
だからこの知ってることには興味がないんですね
本を読んで終わったらもう何のことなくもう捨てます
もう一度読みたい もう一度読みたいという気分にはなりません
もう知りましたと 特に新聞なんかはね
ちょっとひょっと開いて
まあ読み終わったということで処分するでしょう
だから知識の場合でも
まあ過去になると面白くなくなっちゃうんです
だから何かこの本が面白いぞと言ったところで
自分にはその知識あるんだったら
別に何のこともないんだよというんです
それが知識の問題 知識にしたっても
我々の楽しみを妨げるんです
知識あるんだから人生楽しいんじゃなくて
知識あればあるほど楽しめなくなるでしょ？実際に
知識が増えれば増えるほど
人生は楽しめなくなっちゃうんです
素直でいられなくなっちゃうんです
で 感情はもっと厳しいんですよ
じゃあ感情に行きます
エモーションの場合はね
感情っていうのはとんでもないもので Emotions
change the environment to be fit to the nature of emotions.で
例え書いてある Angry
person creates unpleasurable environment. Environment represents our nature
of mindということで
まあ日本訳は適当に日本訳書いてますけど
まあ感情と感情は自分に適合するように環境を変えるのですということで
感情は現実を楽しむんじゃなくて
現実を壊すんですよ 自分に合ってるように
自分に合うように とんでもないやつなんですよ
環境を壊すんです もう例えば怒ってる人は雰囲気も暗くするでしょうね
自分が怒ってるとみんなニコニコと笑ってるのは嫌でしょ
そうするともうあの雰囲気は全部壊しちゃうんです
そんなのは日常茶飯事で
みんな我々やってます
環境を壊すんです 感情で
それでWhatever the case may be, you miss the present moment.そういうことでどうなるのかというと
現実を失ってしまうんです
で  3つも考えてください
過去の経験あると もうあまり面白くなくなっちゃうし
知ってるものだったらもう面白くなくなっちゃうし
今のものはね だから３日目の旅館の滞在は面白くない
なぜ面白くないかというと ２
日間の経験がもう現実を壊してるんで
邪魔しているんで フィルターかけて
知識も同じで 今更絵本なんか読んでも面白くない
なぜかというと いろんな知識あるんだから
これも面白くないんです
そうやって現実をもう妨げちゃうんですね
そこで感情になってくると
現実を妨げるんじゃなくて壊すんです
これ今怒りを例に出したんですが
欲も同じことなんですよ
すっごく楽しく楽しみたい
もう遊びたいと部屋に入った人はさっさと部屋を片付けて
風船やら色々物をつけたりして雰囲気を変えるんです
楽しむために だって日本にしても自然を大事にするんだぞと言っても
何やるかというと片っ端から自然を壊す
あっちこっちすごい厳密に花を植えたり
木を植えて これ以上は伸びるなよとかね
ここへここまでは枝を伸ばすなよとかね
自然じゃないんですね
そういうのは 人間の頭の中で楽しみたいんだから
もう自然を放っておかないんです
もう壊していくんです
それは楽しむためなんです
で 怒りなんか出たらもう壊すんですよ
はっきりと役に立たないように
欲が出てくると役に立つように壊すんです
というか 役に立つかどうかはわかりませんだけど
いっぱい植物あると鳥たちが来たり
虫がついたり 虫がついたら鳥が来るでしょうに
そこでこちょこちょこちょこちょ鳴きながらあっちこち飛んだりするでしょうに
それが自然そのものですけど
我々は欲があるんだから壊す
虫が来たら困ると 鳥がふんをしたらもう葉っぱの上で困ると
それで不自然な人工社会を作るんです
だから感情ぐらいはかなりタチが悪いんですよ
それで感情は過去だとわからないと質問があったでしょう
最初にも では なんで我々は日本庭園作るんでしょうか
それがもう過去から叩き込まれた感情ですよ
今湧いてきた感情で日本庭園は設計しませんよ
画家は絵で感情を表現するでしょう
突然湧いてきた感情を表現するわけじゃないんです
いろんなところで過去の感情
いろいろ過去の経験を引き起こして
引き起こして そこで作品を作るんです
料理作る時でも 奥さんたちはね
全部過去の思い出をね
過去の気持ち 過去の感情を再現しようとしてるんです
どんな味に来るかわからない
やってみようかという感じで誰も料理しません
最後の出来上がりはもう決まってるんです
味も歯触りも香りもなんだかんだでもうレイアウトも決まってるんです
それで本を見ながら料理作るんですよ
それはプロっていう人はもう当然もう過去の感情の引き起こしなんです
だから今突然湧いてきた感情では行動しないんです
過去がなければ怒れませんよ
だから怒って雰囲気を悪くする人も
なぜ怒るのかと怒ったのかというと
過去があったんだからなんです
でないと怒りません だから過去なんです
感情は 今突然怒ったとしたってフィルターかかってるでしょうに
フィルターのせいで怒るんです
例えば 突然私に誰かが嫌なことを言ったとします
別に嫌なこと言ったってただの音ですから
もう言語やら発音やらそのまま聞けばいいでしょうに
しかし 私の過去のいろんなことをこみ上げてきて怒るんですよ
だから 怒りさえもこのフィルターの中で起こる出来事なんです
だからずっと過去がもう関連性
関係を持っています  どんなことになっても現実は知らない
プロのコックさんも現実を見て
すぐその時に何か美味しいものを作るということはできないんです
ずっと過去を生かすんですよ
プロのコックさんに突然新しい材料あげたら
すぐ料理作ってくださいということ作れますよ
プロだから でもその時も過去の経験
過去の感情 過去の味 で
合成して生かすんです
まあそんなことで まあそんなに難しくないね
今日は じゃあすぐに行きます
それでDriven by emotions man destroys the life destroys the nature
wage wages wars
と訳れてばいいと思います and
wage wars creates conflicts and drags the life into a
n extremely awful situation.
N
o war is possible if man adhere to rationality and stop becoming a slave to
emotions.ということで
で あのemotion生命の破壊
自然破壊 戦争 争いなどは感情により現れる
感情はすごく悪いんです
何でも壊す 欲の感情も怒りの感情も
どんな感情であろうとも
もう壊しちゃうんですよ
普段は怒ったら壊すぐらい覚えてるでしょ
だから政治家の世界で
経済の世界で みんな豊かで金があれば喧嘩しないでしょうとか思ったりするでしょうに
そうじゃないんですよ
ものすごい豊かになっているアメリカも自然も何でも壊すんです
すごく豊かになっている日本社会も
もう何から何まで壊していくんですよ
だから欲であろうと怒りであろうか
嫉妬であろうか 力士であろうか
落ち込みであろうか もう何かを壊す
落ち込んだ人は自分を壊す
あれ 感情っていうのは壊し屋ですからね
だから我々人間っていうのはなんでも壊す
動物でも感情が出てくると壊すんですよ
でないとぐーっとベッタリと寝てますけどね
時々感情を起こすんですね
動物も その時はもう壊しに行くんです
戦うんです オランウータンいますね
かなり人間に近い動物で
戦わないんであまり でも雨が降ると熱帯だからオランウータン住んでる
大体マレーシアにいますしね
面白いんですよ 雨が降ると森の中にいるんだから
大きい葉っぱとか取って頭にそうやってつけてるんです
体がビショ濡れですけど
お腹も大きいし それでこれでなんとか雨宿しようかなと
だからもう雨に濡れたくないというね
という欲があるんですよ
それで自然壊してるでしょ
葉っぱ 1枚取ったことも壊しですからね
厳密に言えば 取って食べてならば壊しですけど
それはしょうがないんですよ
それはもう避けられない
それで寝る 時はちゃんと葉っぱ持ってきて
枝の上にちゃんと拭いておいて
その上に寝るんです これだったらよく雨に濡れないで寝られるせいと思って寝るんですけど
雨が降っちゃうともうザーッと濡れちゃいますけどね
どうかわからないんだけど
1年中雨が降ってるは乾くはあるわもう
なのにオランウータンは水が嫌いという
という面白い動物です
ですから 感情っていうのはいかなる場合でも壊すんです
それによって生きることは苦悩に満ちる
まあ一応アバウトで英訳を 2行目に日本訳しましたけどね
英語の達人の方々はきちんと訳してくれてもありがたいんですけど
それで理性を保ち 感情の奴隷になることをやめるなら
戦争なんかは起こるものではありません
人間を起こしたすべての戦争は感情の戦争なんですよ
理性の戦争はないんです
インチキな話を聞いて感情を引き起こして人殺しに行くんです
人間は理性でいるならばね
感情の奴隷にならないならば
破壊に 壊し屋にはいかないんです
破壊生活しながら 壊し屋の生活しながら
結局はみんなテロなんですよ
皆様も このテロ活動しながら幸せあるわけないでしょうに
有名なテロリストでビンラデンがもうかなり知識人で金持ちでしょうし
豊かで幸せでいられないでしょう
体もすごい病気だそうです
透析なんとかという そうやらなくちゃいけないし
でも苦労してますよ なぜかというと
テロリストだと言われてるんだから
だから幸福はないんでしょうね
我々ももう何を隠そう立派なテロリストなんです
感情を持ってるんだから
これでもう片っ端から壊してるんです
それで現実は見えなくなっちゃって
楽しみが消えてしまうんです
こちらでこの様々な まあ一応この一つ一つの説明はそれで一応大体終わりと思いますけどね
過去の説明 過去っていうのは3種類よく覚えてください
経験 知識 感情 これで仏教的な順番は感情
経験 知識なんです 人間が知識っていうのはもうほとんど使わない
生きる時は 使っても少ない
いつでも使ってる過去の経験っていうのは感情なんです
はい 次のポイントに行きます
それで感情って何なのかとね
まだ感情の説明 Emotion
such as greed, anger, hatred, jealousy, vanity etc. resurre
ct from the grave
of past and destroy the calmness of life at the present moment.で
今生きる人にとってはこの欲
怒り 何でしたっけね 苦しみ
嫉妬 慢などの感情が過去から蘇る
過去からでって私はgraveと書いたんですけど
ちょっと日本訳難しい grave
って何でしたっけ？墓ですかね
過去の墓から蘇ってきて
お化けですからね 過去は
今現在生きることの安らぎを壊す
今現在生きるということはそんな難しいことではないんですが
この安らぎを壊しちゃうんですよ One
who expects a happy life does not let emotions to usurping one's life.で
これusurpingの訳わからなかったんです
楽しく生きるために 生きるためには
感情が人生を何でしたっけ
横領ですか  横領しないようにとか気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
感情が横領しているんですよ
我々の人生を usurping
っていうのは横領というよりもちょっときつい言葉ですけど
この強引に戦略して もう支配して
もう何もやらせないという
例えばイラク人にアメリカ人がやっていることみたいに
イラク人には何もできない
政府作りますや 何とか選挙でもやります
と言ったっても 何一つも正しく民主主義的にはやらせません
自分たちの支配下の気分でやるんです
そんな感じで 今現在も起きているんだから
昔ははっきり起きていたでしょうし
人の国を奪っちゃうと
その国民にはどうすることもできない
そういう風に私たちは自由な人間だと思っちゃえば
自由は奪われているんです
植民地になっているんで
奴隷になっている 誰にかというと感情に
だから感情が我々の人生を横領しないようにと気をつければ
そちらに幸福があるんです
そちらに自由も独立もあるんです
それで感情っていうものは
過去っていうものは やっぱり墓からよみがえってくるお化けなんです
決して実物でもないんです
なのによくやられていますよ
はい それから全く別なポイント
では今まで過去に悪口言ってきたんですけど
では将来って何なのかと
将来って何なのかと Future
means the past disguised という英語のタイトルを付けたんです Future
将来というのは過去が化けてるだけ
将来に化ける過去 だから将来ということは
将来はそういうことなんです
とにかくあるかないかではなくて
我々の将来 将来というのは単なる過去が将来として化けてるんですよ
化け物 どうせ物の怪だからね
いろんな形に化けますよ
これはすごいちょっとした微妙なポイントなんです Your
plans, dreams, projects, hopes, expectations, anticipations
などなど are no less
than your past in pretense of future.あなたのプランで計画であろうが
夢であろうが プロジェクトであろうか
希望期待であろうか それは将来の具体的なイメージではないんです
単に過去が将来として化けただけなのです
それで何かプラン作るでしょ
そのプランというのは過去の経験
過去の考え方 過去の感情をプランとして表す
書くだけで 作るだけで
結局は過去のプロダクションですよ
何が期待するんだと言っても
これはまるっきり過去で知らなかったら期待できないでしょ
だから私は将来何々期待してるんだよと言っても
それが感情として過去なんです
例えば 母親が自分の子供が弁護士になることを期待しているんだと
高校生を それで今まだ高校生だからね
それ将来期待してると思いますか？違うんです
その母親が弁護士を知ってるんです
それでかっこいいと思ってるんです
それが期待しているんであって
大体母親は子供はもうちょっと形になったら体どんな風に変わるか
それさえも知らないのに
三十歳になったらどんな風な男になるのか知らないんですよ
なのに 「うちの子は将来期待しています」と 「
弁護士になることは」と
それは決して将来の期待じゃなくて
過去なんです それまだ論理的な過去じゃないんだから
なおさら悪いんですよ
例えば五年前に「あの人に私は騙されたな」と
と怒るのは一応論理的な過去なんです
いまだに怒っているよと
それで自分の人生はダメになりますが
いくらか論理的でしょうに
だから 自分の息子が将来医者になることやら弁護士になることやらと期待する場合は
これはもう全くヘリクツも有り
もうとんでもないごちゃごちゃした過去なんです
だから 過去に足を引っ張られるのはどうしようもなくたっても
この将来にやれることだけはとても危険なんです
だから仏教は堂々とこの希望・欲望・願望っていうのは
これはとてつもない苦しみの苦難の道になるんだよと
大変な精神的な混乱を引き起こす羽目になるんです Future
dreams are another source of human suffering.ですから
将来に対する期待することも
将来に対する期待も苦の原因になるのです
いっぱい夢があるんだったらいっぱいもう限りなく苦しむ羽目になります
あれこれといっぱい期待してるんだったら
もうよっぽどの馬鹿者なんですよ
もうもうあまりにもねじ曲がってるんですよ
もう 将来 過去 すごい苦しむことになるんです
何か難しいところあります？そこら辺で
このポイントはちょっと普段は皆様はそうだと思わないポイントですから
今日覚えてください だから全くもう大胆な思考だから
反論あるならば今のうちですけど出してください
でないと私の考え方で全部抑えていくんです
何か違う意見でもあるならばちょっと待ちます
はい では次に行きます
それでMaintenance of the past
では過去はどうやってメンテナンスするのかというね
過去の処理方法 もう過去についてもう全部説明終わりました
それで一番大きな問題点 One
cannot forget the past
過去を忘れようと言っても
これできることじゃないでしょ？いくら化け物やとかなんとか言ったっても
言うのは簡単ですけど 「
じゃあ忘れましょう」と言ったってそれは難しい But
it does not exist.過去を忘れることはできないが
過去が現実 実現するものではありません
実際 実際するものではないんです
それだけわかってほしい
過去を忘れてくださいと言ったっても
これはちょっともう人間には難しいんです Since
the past is the motive force of present living,
one cannot ignore it altogether.
そこでなぜ忘れられないのかというと
生きることの衝動になっているので
完全に無視することもできません
我々今生きている馬力
エネルギーは過去だから
無視するということはできないんですよ
で これから終わったら駅までいらっしゃるでしょ
過去の経験がないと無理でしょうに
家に帰りたいというemotion
感情がないと どこ行くかわからないでしょ
人間が だけど家には帰りたくないという感情が出たら家に帰らないでしょ
どこか飲み屋さんに行くんだから
だから我々の日常の行動っていうのは
どう見たっても過去がエネルギーになって生きてるんだから
もう綺麗にさっぱり忘れなさい
忘れなさいと言ったっても
ちょっと忘れるのは難しいんですね
無視するのは難しい でも気をつけて管理しないと
我々の幸福を全部壊すんです
今日のポイントはそういうことなんです
ということで また続きます
それでどういうことかというと
私は前に分析してあげたでしょう
十 十二種類ね その中にThere are some profitable aspects in the past
過去にはやっぱりいい側面もあります
過去に過去と言っても
それは一色ではなく 有効な役に立つ側面があるのです
それで過去の有効な側面のみを生かして今の生き方を向上すればいい
それで過去をきれいさっぱり忘れるんじゃなくて
あの十二種類のところからいいところだけ取って
それだけを生かすんです
そこで生かして今生きている
そうすると幸せになりますよ
幸福になります 単純な論理ですけどね
はい 次に行きます そこでもう一度元の説明にまた戻ります
セットで一番大きなのはすごい性質が悪いのは感情ですね
次にエクスペリエンス経験ですね
それから知識ですね それもジェネラル
どうしても必要な普通なものが三つありまして
役に立つものがあって
役に全く立たないものがあって
破壊的なものがあります
この三つで それをもう一度覚えておいてください
はい 次に行きます それで一つずつ説明します
あの 一二三四順番変えたんだから
即席の立場から ですから
その立場で説明します
一番目 エクスペリエンス経験の場合は
普通な経験というのは普通な生活に必要な部分
例えば皆様お箸を使う経験あるでしょうに
それさえなければ生きていられないでしょうに
服をどうやって着るのかとかね
靴はどのように履くのかとかね
お風呂はどのように使うのかとか
そういう経験っていうのはごく普通な経験で必要なものなんです
で 外国に行ったらどうすればいいのかとかね
そういうぐらいの経験があれば結構楽に生きていられます
それ 普通な経験 それからプロフィタブルという有効に役に立つ経験っていうのは何なのかというと
例えばテクノロジー あるいは修行することとかね
それはすごく役に立つんですよ
技術など生活に欠かせないもの
例えば英語を勉強してその通訳の仕事をしているんだったら
その経験っていうのは役に立つでしょ
食べていくためには だから過去と言ったっても
それが忘れて困るでしょうに
まあ技術といったら いつでも工学的な技術だけじゃないんですよ
英語を学ぶことも技術なんです
仏教から言えば あの教員の免許を取って教員になることは
それはもう技術なんですね
それから教えることで生計を立てる
書道を習って それから書道の先生になったら
それで収入を得て生きている
そのように あのプロフィタブル経験というのはあります
役に立つ経験 そこでアンプロフィタブル経験
役に立たない経験もあります
例えば万引きしたことがありますと
役に立ちますかね それが
ではこれからこの経験を生かすぞというと困るでしょうに
次は何でしたっけ？読み方
いたずら いたずらする経験が
それはいじめなど 私はよく学校で同級生をいじめたいじめたんだよとかね
そういう経験ありますって言っても役に立たんでしょうに
その経験を生かしてあげましょうと言うとごめんでしょうに
だから経験といったっても全く役に立たない経験もあります
無駄な経験 そこでこのエクスペリエンスオブクライメンバイオレンス
いわゆるデストラクティブという破壊的な経験は何なのかというと
犯罪を起こした経験があるとかね
私は人殺したことありますからね
大丈夫です 任せてくださいと言うと大丈夫ですかね
強盗したことありますからね
こういう破壊的な経験っていうのは破壊的なんです
それで経験はそういうふうに４つに分けてください ４
つに分けたところで ジェネラルと私は書いている経験っていうのは
全ての人間に必要なもので
いいとも悪いとも言えない
それでないと生きていられない
2番目は より幸福に何か職でも見つけて生きていられますから
その過去の経験も大事なんです
下の 3つは 普通 2つはもう捨ててほしいんです
さて これから我々は過去の経験を生かす場合は
綺麗に 2つはもう捨ててしまう
思い出そうともしないで
上の 2つだけで生きてみる
それは経験の場合はそういうことなんです
次に行きます 知識の場合
これはあまり人は使ってないんだからね
本当は 3番目にした方がいいんですけど
しかしこのエモーションというのは大胆だからね
知識の場合はまた普通なジェネラル知識っていうことは普通な生活に必要な部分ですよ
例えば日本語読めるとか
皆様日本語が読めなかったらもう大変でしょう
駅で迷子になっちゃって
手紙ぐらい読めるとか
そういう普通な経験 それでプロフィタブルと有効に役に立つ経験というのは
エデュケーションノレッジオブトゥルースという仕事に必要な学問
時々普通の会社に入った入って 1人前仕事をするんだけど
ちょっと英語を勉強したこともありまして
役に立ちましたと 突然外国人が商売に来たところで
もう誰も英語を喋れない人が
じゃあ私は喋ってあげましょうということで出かける出ることできますでしょうに
そういうことで 必ず自分の仕事内容でなくても
いろいろちょびちょびと知った方が
いつか役に立ってくれる時もあります
そこで心理の勉強と書いたのは
もう別にブッダの教えを勉強しておいた方がいいんです
すっと役に立ちます こういうへりくつな頭が綺麗に直してくれます
きちんと淡々と物事を考えて
瞬時に判断できて すごい幸せに生きていられる方法を教えているんです
決して宗教だからとお祈りする暗い教えじゃなくて
すごい大胆で堂々と言っている教えなんです
ブッダの教えっていうのは
ですから 心理の勉強っていうのは欠かせないんで
それも役に立つことで
役に立たない勉強って何ですかね
ラーニングオブハウ これ間違ってますね
ハウトゥディストロイライフ
オプティミズムとユースレススタディーズしたということで
生命に害を与える知識
どうすればこれ殺せるかとかね
どうすれば動物を捕まえるのかとかね
そういう知識ですね あるいはそれからこの楽観主義も知識的に勉強して楽観主義者になっちゃうと
もうろくな人間にならないんですよ
それから無駄な勉強いっぱいやってるでしょ
まあどうでもいい漫画読んだりとかね
特に子供たちの漫画の中であらゆる怪獣が出たりとかね
何の道徳も何のメッセージもない
また ものすごい難しい名前を付けたりして
あれ全部子供たちは覚えてるんですよ
大人もとんでもない泥棒やって金儲けてるんですよ
それで子供たちは被害者になる
そういう無駄な勉強もあります
それはもう 役に立たないもの
それで破壊的な勉強っていうのは一応破壊主義者になる
勉強して会議主義者になる
自然に人間懐疑主義じゃないんですよ
いろんなことを勉強すると懐疑主義者になっちゃうんです
あるいは戦争論やる 学問までやりますから
毒の合成 兵器に対する知識とかね
そんなものは破壊的 勉強するとやりたくなるんです
あのビンラディンの話の中でも
ごく普通に まあちょっといい加減な人みたいでしたけど
どこかどこかで行ったところで
このイスラム教理教理というんですか
それはとことん叩いて教えてくれたんだと
そうすると自分が普通が不良みたいな
もういろんな もうすごい一般的に
まあ男だからね あれこれとやっていたんですけど
それで自分がすごくおとなしくなりましたと
そういうイスラムの教理を勉強したところでどうなったかというと
テロになって終わっちゃったんです
だからやっぱりあの それも破壊的なかわいそうで
イスラム教理学ではそういう部分がありますよ
もうテロをこう あの 養成する教えというね
まあ平和を謳っている部分もあります
これは知識の場合もそうやって 4つあります
その 4つの中で 我々は上の 2つは真剣に取り入れる
ブッダの教えでも勉強したりして
仕事に必要なことも勉強して
日常茶飯事に必要なことも勉強して
完璧な人間になればいいんです
下の 2つはもうきれいさっぱり捨ててしまう
時間あるならば役に立つ本を読んでください
何にも役に立たない ただ読んだそうってぐらいの本なんかは読まないでください
本でもちゃんと選んだ方がいいんです
我々を騙して金を奪う取るために書いてる本もいっぱいあります
自分に何が役に立つか
仕事にか人生にかどちらかなんですよ
役に立つものだけ選んで読んだ方がいいんです
それは知識の場合は 最後にエモーションですね
で  1番目はジェネラル
誰にでもまあなくてはならない感情がありますね
普通な生活に必要な優しさ
思いやり そんな大したことじゃないんですよ
普通に生きるために必要でしょう
子供のこと心配するとか
ああ 可愛いと思っちゃうとかね
子供が楽しくはしゃいで遊んでると
自分ももう調子に乗って一緒に遊んであげるとか
そういう感情ないと生きていられないでしょうね
だって我々外人はこういう東京であちこち行ったりすると
もう一人外人が会うとちゃんと挨拶してニコッと笑って
知らない 何者かと思う
でもその瞬間でよく知ってるような感じで挨拶をする
あれ本当に嬉しいんですよ
私でもそうやって人を介して
私もすごい真面目に そういう笑ってニコッと笑って挨拶しますけど
その瞬間であっ 自分と同じ
寂しくないんだと 仲間がいるんだと
という気分になるんですよ
それで日常生活の中で
そういう風に おばあちゃん大変でしょうとかね
ちょっと協力してあげようとかね
子供は可愛いと それぐらいの感情っていうのは人間には必要
それはジェネラルですね
一般的な感情で それで役に立つ感情っていうのは
やっぱりこれが難しいんですね
仏教から人粋に言えば
これ慈しみなんですよ
生命に対する慈しみ 生き物を大事にしなくちゃと
それで生命に対して哀れみですか
生き物を心配している
心配することの哀れみといっても
苦しんではならないと
できることなら助けてあげたいんだと
という感情っていうのはすごく役に立つ
だから感情の場合は 人間というのはどうもここら辺
有効な感情を持ってないみたいんですよ
すごく質が悪いというのはそういうわけなんです
慈しみのところが自分だけ良ければいいという感情で生きているでしょう
それで不幸になっちゃうんです
幸せがなくなっちゃうんです
だからみんな幸せでいてほしいと
何人であろうか どんな宗教の人であろうか
人間はみんな幸せになってほしい
人間だけじゃない すべての生命はもう仲間ですから
幸せでいてほしいと それはうちの子が可愛いということとものすごい違いますよ
うちの子が可愛いと思わなきゃ育てませんから
そんなのはもうごく普通な感情で
ではなくて 生命はことごとくみんな可愛いと思うことが大変尊い感情で
それでものすごい立派な人間になって
どこにいたっても楽しく生きてられる
それからまたいい感情
確信というのはね 何かやるにしたっても
ちゃんと確信があって
自信があって生活すること
曖昧中途半端ではなくて
しっかりと確信 それも仏教のリストたくさんあります
リストの中からいくつか出しただけで
それから勇気というものも一つ感情なんですよ
勇気は必要でしょ？臆病よりはね
明るさ とにかく明るくいる
それから与える気持ちっていうのは
いつでも協力する体制でいる
何か役に立つことがあったらすぐやってあげますという
それだったらこの世の中ですごく気楽に生きていられます
与える気持ち それで場所がないんだから予約入れてないんです
いろいろ場所がなくなっちゃったんです
それ 2つだけで来てほしい感情で
しかし 皆様にしたっても
ジェネラルという感情はあると思いますよ
でなきゃ生きていられませんから
ないんですよ 役に立つ感情は
これがもう育てないと幸せになれません
2番目 頑張って育ててほしい
3番目は役に立たない感情
もう分かりやすいこと
欲 怒り 無知 暗さ 落ち込み
怠け こんなのは役に立つ？立たないでしょ
だからそんなのはもう捨て
捨てなくちゃいけない
それで破壊的な感情っていうのは
この病的な欲 欲と言っていられない
病気なんです これは怒りも同じ
病的な怒りがあるんです
ちょっと怒ったところじゃないんです
もう病的 あの女の子みたいに
そこで全てを疑う極端な懐疑主義
もう何でも人を疑うは
あれも疑うは これを疑うは
もうそんなもんで生きていられますかね
だから極端な懐疑主義もすごい感情なんです
知識でも何でもないんです
知識あるんだったら疑わないでしょ
無知なんです 無知の感情がすごい極端な
病的になってしまうんです
無知も 病的になるともう何一つも信じられなくなっちゃうんです
そうすると自殺するしかなくなっちゃうんですね
それで下の 2つはもう切りさったり捨てる
捨てて上の 2つで生きてみようとする
一番すごい難しい 理解も難しくて慣れるも難しいのはこの感情のセットなんです
大体こういう風にこの
[背景音楽]見てみれば
このこの過去にも良い側面があるんだよと
それまた二つ二つで三種類ですから
えーと六ですね 六種類あるということを理解して実践してほしいなというところです
はい まあそろそろ終わると思います
それでまたもう一度Maintenance of Pastというタイトルに戻りました
処理方法 で 結論ですけど One
must be calm enough to select the beneficial aspects alone of the pas
t.我々は落ち着いてないと
この過去から良いものだけ選ぶことできないんですよ
頭混乱しちゃうと何を選ぶか分からないんですよ
だから常に落ち着いていた方がいいんです
そうすると 万引きした経験があっても
それは使わない 忘れておいておくんです
落ち着きがなくなっちゃうと万引きしちゃうんですよ
もう大人も万引きするんだからね
子供はもう極端に落ち着きがなくなっちゃうと万引きしたりする
それが大人もやっちゃいます
だからこの落ち着いていないと良いところだけ選ぶことはできなくなるんです
過去の有効な経験のみを選びられるように
常に落ち着いた方が良い Maintaining
calmness around the clock is a must to achieve the happiness of life.ですから
常に落ち着いていることは
幸福に生きる人にとって欠かせない条件です
これ  round the clock
いつでも落ち着いてほしいんです
朝だけ落ち着いて 昼は混乱するとかね
こう言うと話にならない
寝る時も落ち着いていてほしい
落ち着きっていうのは
もう round the clock で
まあ二十四時間やらなくちゃいけないんですね
そうするとどうなるかというと
我々は選ぶんですよ 過去から良いところだけ選んで
今の人生に衝動にするんです
はい これでどうなるかというと
障害物の認定 一応もうこれから認定しないとね Authorized
roadblocks to happiness Authorized
っていうのは もうまあ公でちゃんと認定しているんですよ
このroadblocks Happiness
に対するこの障害物をね
それは何なのかと これで結論です Endless
strain of aimless wandering of the mind is the sole culprit
who destroys the
happiness of life.もう簡単に日本語で書いてます
無限に回転する妄想の流れが
我々の生きる楽しみを破壊
なんか間違った破壊する犯人なのです
壊す犯人なのです それで我々は無限に妄想しているでしょう
これが認定します してください
これを これが幸福を壊す犯人として公認です
これが  [音楽]ですから Guard your wandering m
ind and discover the happiness of life 妄想を制御し
幸福を獲得するということをしてほしい
ごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ妄想しないであれこれやと全て妄想という一言葉にまとめます
だからこれで話は終了しますが
この何でしたっけ？我々の幸福を壊す障害物って何なのかというと
一言葉で言えば妄想です
だから化け物なんです
妄想は何なのかというと過去なんです
ということで 猿様大変困っているところで
妄想をどう管理しようかなと
で まあ終わりとします
はい で それで今日のテーマは一応ここら辺で終了いたします
まあ少々時間ございますので
質問とかアイデアとかあれば
あのいいですか えっと
今あの仏教のお話で あのカマータっていう怠けっていうのが一番悪いっていう風に考えてるんですけど
今の分類だとあの役に立たないってところに怠けちゃって
破壊的とまではっていうところには分類されてなかったんですけど
あのそうするとなんとなくニュアンスとして
まあ悪いけどまあしょうがないみたいな感じの受け止め方なんですけど
だから怠けっていうのは怠けやすら破壊するんですかね
やっぱりそこら辺でこのエネルギーの問題で
極端に病的に怠けると自己破壊どちらからも生まれますから
大体あまり自己破壊は今日あんまり扱って扱ってないんです
怠け極端になると ただ自己破壊でそのままドーンボケーっているだけでしょ
だからまあ破壊的と言ったっても
じわじわと自分が破壊に行くだけ
怠ける人は自殺さえもしないんだからね
だからアッパマパーダっていうのは怠けることじゃないんですね
それはもうもうもう無知の一つで
このやっぱり妄想することなんですね
パーマーでのこの瞬間
瞬間 瞬間 その気づいていないところをパーマーダというんですね
ですから 今日のテーマにはちょっと扱いにくいんです
他何かありますか？何かありますか
で はい  欲について聞きたいんですけど
欲は役に立たないという話だったんですが
人と話してて出た話題なんですけど
例えばいい人になりたいとか
そういった欲は必要ではないのかという話になったんですが
どうなのかというのを私は
それは我々日本語ですいぶん簡単に何だかんだも欲という言葉でまとめるんですけど
仏教になってくるとどんな言葉も定義して意味をはっきりするんですよ
欲っていうのは いい人間になりたいっていうことは
それで欲とは定義に入りません
欲っていうのは このものを自分でものものにしたがるんですよ
例えば見るもの 聞くもの
味わうもの 俺のものにしたがるんです
楽しいんだから と それが欲と呼ぶんです
例えばいい人間になりたいという場合は
何かこれであれ 自分のものにしたい
これ自分のものにしたいという気持ちがない場合は綺麗ですよ
だから欲っていうのは五欲
それを収穫しようと 自分のものにしようと
例えば可愛い人が見たら
何としてでも自分の手に入るようにするぞというと
それは明らかに欲なんです
その人がすごい立派な人でいることを見たところで
やっぱり自分も頑張らなくちゃという場合は
これは悪い欲じゃないんです
それは向上心であって
だから俗世間で言う何だかんだも欲と一言葉に
考えるのは問題なんです
あともう一つ  はい  現在が見れ
現在フィルターかかってて現在を経験してないという話だったんですけど
それが過去になるってことですよね
要は過去っていうのももう不確かなもの
過去は一応存在しないんだから
一応ね まあもう化け物でしょ
それで過去は現在から作るでしょ
結局は 時間の流れで過去になるでしょ
その現在もろくに知ってないでしょ
フィルターかかっていて
それの積み重ねの過去だから
当てにならない 過去でその花が見たことありますよって言っても
その時もろくに見てないんだから当てにならないんですよ
当てにならないものでフィルター
そうそう だからもう倍悪いんですよ
どんどん増幅して  増えていくんです
例えば生まれ変わったら
またきれいさっぱり忘れますけど
その時もやっぱりかすかにフィルターかけてます
生まれた瞬間でも それから新しくどんどんフィルター増やしちゃうんです
それはもう無限にフィルター増やすってことはもうありえないので
フィルターにも容量というものはありますからね
無限に容量になってくると
その人がもう破壊になっちゃうんです
例えば 怒りのフィルターが赤線までいっちゃうと
自分で死ぬか人を殺すかっていうことになって
それでも終わっちゃうんですよ
欲もこの赤線まで欲のフィルターかけちゃうと
そのまま発作を起こして死ぬんです
だからフィルター自体にもどれぐらいゴミが入れるのかというこの容量っていうのはあるんです
そこで幸いに人が死ぬんだから
それで全部忘れちゃって
例えば死んで別のところに生まれたら
今までの過去っていうのは全然役に立たないでしょ
だから過去に今引っかかっていても意味がないんですよ
例えば 今よく英語を勉強したとする
それでその人が死んじゃって
アフリカで生まれる あの英語はもうとっくに忘れて役に立ってないんですよ
これが大事だというと
人と喧嘩して不幸な人生こちらでやっても
結局は経験っていうのは捨てます
全部 ただ 過去生に将来にこのちょっとした影響というか
もう傾きぐらいは残るんですよ
フィルターの原型はできています
それからそこから入る情報でも
あの原型の上で新しいフィルターを作る
私たちもこの世で作るフィルターは必ずしも外から作ったわけじゃなくて
自分も原型を持ってるんです
その原型の上でお母さんが言ったことを
お父さんが言うことを
先生が言うことを入れて入れてフィルター作るんです
だから個人差がみんなにあるんです
この個人差は過去から持ってきたフィルターの原型なんです
それも変わるんですよ
いろいろ そういうことでね
フィルターはあまりろくでもないフィルターなんですよ
過去で作るんですけど
その加工もろくでもないものでできている加工でしょうし
現在見てないでしょうし
ということで結論と言えるのはもう全然当てにする必要ないんです
だから何か選んで役に立つところだけちょっとそこに
はい で 他何か意見ご意見等ございますか
常に落ち着いているっていうことが非常に重要なんですけど
落ち着きがない人にとってはどういうことを注意すれば落ち着いていられるんですか
落ち着けって面白い 落ち着けって言ったら落ち着くんですよ
あまり真剣に考えちゃって実行できないんですよ
落ち着けこのバカと言えばもう落ち着くんです
もう今日は一般的な仏教の話で
別に解脱の話とか修行の話とか瞑想の話じゃないんだから
あくまでも素人レベルでいかなくちゃいけないんです
ですからまあただ俗世間では落ち着けこのバカと言えばもう落ち着きますから
その程度で十分ですよ
日常生活では 例えば奥さんでもえらい感情発作を起こしてガチャギャーギャー言うと
ちょっと落ち着いたら話聞いてあげますよと
そうすると落ち着くんですよ
女性っていうのは落ち着いたら何も言うことないんです
感情がもう発作起こしちゃうと
もうしゃべりたくてしゃべりたくてもう切りがないんですけど
落ち着け 落ち着いたらもう真剣に話聞いてあげるぞと男が言ったらそれだけで落ち着くんですよ
それから問題は何なのか
いえ 何でもないと言うんです
いいですと だからこのいざ時間に落ち着くっていうのは
まあそれぐらいのこと
だから自分 我々も個人自分に言い返せばいいんです
落ち着けと こんなんでうまくいくはずないんだと
落ち着けと自分に言っちゃえば落ち着くんです
はい まあそれで じゃあどうも